oh thank you so much
good morning everyone it's a great
pleasure uh to be here and talking about
a cool technical framework they
developed to help optimize digital
experiments
and the work is motivated by use cases
in digital experimentation and some of
them are Behavior change campaigns that
we conduct at CBS health
um so I would like to first introduce
um yeah myself you already heard I'm a
principal data scientist at CVS health
and then this is read our main working
force a data scientist also at CBS house
and also we have a project team
um this include our senior manager
Mariam lead the director the business
sponsor Jason and also our two sponsors
Dan and Francis and also I wanted to
thank our collaborators who helped
motivate the initial work that motivated
the development of this novel framework
the argentian who was a data scientist
in CBS Health in 2021 and also Shruti
another business partner
okay so here is the outline of the talk
uh first I'll give some overall
motivation and intuition of the new
framework we developed
and then I will hand over to read and he
will talk walk you through in detail the
background the message
the new development
overview results and applications
and also we wanted to just talk a little
bit about a new python package that we
are building uh to autopiloting contact
to motor and Bandit models simulation
evaluation and their usage
okay so here's a take-home message so I
wanted everyone to take at least this
message home after this talk so
um compared to multiply and Bandit is an
effective method for optimizing
recommendations and improving
personalization in an efficient way
yeah so the problem uh they are often
facing in digital experimentation is to
match eligible users with a set of
actions such as a set of different ads a
set of different offers to optimize for
business outcomes
to maximize for rewards and minimize for
regrets in an efficient way
is a personalized version of
multi-around Bandit and it's not a new
technique
but what is new here is how we frame our
business problem into a technical
problem and fit our unique business
problem we think a general framework
based on contextual motor and Bandit
I'll just jump to one more slide here
okay so this one yeah so basically sorry
not this one yet next slide yeah okay
so one of the motivating examples so
here I'm only talking about the toric's
toy example and a fake example because
this is for company proprietary
information
uh so for example we have visitors uh to
Amazon the shopping side and we have a
bunch of ads to show to each visitors
and each ad is about
applying for a different Financial
Services like a credit card or
a debit card offer and then if someone
successfully can work and apply they
give them like a gift card of 10.30
fifty dollars and we only have a couple
of slots to show such as
so the cost has opportunity costs have
the dollar cost and also have cost
um our customer satisfaction because uh
think about if we keep showing to our
customers so as they don't want to see
then this may annoy them and disrupt
their disturb they are shopping
purchasing experience right so we wanted
to optimize given a state so the state
here is at a given point in time and at
the contextual
status of the user with the
user's features like profile profile
demographics and their shopping history
and show them the action from a bunch of
different eligible actions so that we
can pick the next best action to show to
them at the next time point to maximize
our business outcome such as CTR click
through conversion
and then we can we will continue
iterating this whole process until we
reach the final optimal so contextual
motor embedded will make this whole
process as efficient as possible
and also I wanted to point out here we
also can incorporate constraints uh for
the overall overall rewards and also
overall uh regrets yeah and because of
the nature of the problem think about
the state as our data think about
actions as also other part of Prior
information and the rewards
is our posterior based on the current
data and the prior so this is naturally
falling into a patient framework okay so
I will hand this over to read who will
walk us through in detail
cool thanks all right so
taking a step back from contextual
multi-arm Bandit let's first start off
with an overview of vanilla multi-arm
band as we can kind of build up this
knowledge base and then actually
understand what contextual maybe is so
before I dive into this can I get a
quick show of hands how many people here
are actually familiar with vanilla
multi-arm Bandit methods
okay a couple all right cool so
like we showed in the previous slide
all these multi-arm banded methods
vanilla or contextual they fall under
the general umbrella of reinforcement
learning right so in reinforcement
learning you have a state or you have an
agent right this agent is in some State
um
it has to select some action once it
does so it observes a reward and the
objective of this agent is to learn some
policy such that you can optimally
select actions in order to maximize
cumulative sum of rewards and minimize
regret right that's reinforcement
learning multi-arm Bandit the vanilla
case is a simplification of this General
reinforcement learning framework in that
you
ignore the state right so now you're in
this setting where you're just trying to
pick actions that give the best reward
and you have to come up with some
strategy to optimally do that
to make this a little more concrete you
can think of an example that's shown in
the cartoon on the bottom right here
where you quite literally have a
multi-armed bandit that's pulling let's
say five different slot machines right
and the Bandit doesn't know how much
money is going to be returned from each
of these slot machines and so this
bandit has to at each point in time pick
which slot machine to pull from and the
objective of the Bandit is of course to
maximize winnings
so
the problem here that the Bandit has to
solve is What's called the exploration
exploitation trade-off right of course
in the beginning the Bandit has no
information whatsoever so it's going to
randomly pick slot machines to pull from
then as we have pulled a couple times
it's gonna now it has some data to work
with right it sees maybe slot machine
three give us some money a couple times
slot machine one gave us nothing a
couple times right it gets this data and
now the question is what do we do with
this data right we can use this data and
say
you know the data's telling us that slot
machine 3 is best so maybe we just
picked that 100 of the time but that's
not good because what if you just got
really unlucky with slot machine one
because it's a small sample size but in
reality if you kept pulling it maybe it
gives you something better
and so this kind of highlights why we
need to balance between exploring
unknown actions that might have a really
high reward versus exploiting what the
data is showing us is the best action at
this moment in time because we'll never
actually know the ground truth and so we
can never take a purely exploitative
strategy we always need to be exploring
to some degree in order to ensure that
we don't get stuck in a local Optimum
um
okay
so another way you can think of these
mab algorithms is kind of
um you know analogously to a b testing
you know if you were to try to solve
this
um you know the slot machine problem you
could also take an approach like a b
testing right instead of doing this mab
stuff you could just say okay we're
going to run an experiment and if
there's five slot machines we're going
to pull each one 20 of the time we can
do it a thousand times at the end of it
we'll run some analysis get a p-value
check for statistical significance see
which one is the best right and you
could do that and that's fine and good
and there's plenty of business
situations where this is desirable right
if you have a really critical business
decision you need some Metric for
statistical significance you have
stakeholders that are really tied to
important kpis in that case a b testing
is a fine methodology to use I'm sure
you all are familiar with it but in a
lot of cases now there are situations
where there's a high opportunity cost
you desire more continuous optimization
automation something of that nature and
in these settings mab can provide you
with these things and actually provide
advantageous qualities and better
outcomes generally than a b testing
because it allows you to kind of
dynamically optimize right A B testing
you're just you know you set your
allocation at 20 a piece for a thousand
iterations and you don't change that
right but you could see after maybe only
15 iterations that maybe slot machine
one is really bad but you're going to
keep pulling it because that's the way
you designed your experiment multi-arm
Bandit can use that information in real
time and say all right this slot machine
doesn't seem to be doing so well so
we're going to kind of ease away from
that and move in favor of the one that
does seem to be doing well not ignore it
entirely because like I said before you
always need to be exploring
um
but it allows you to dynamically adjust
your allocation to each of these actions
so that was a
quick high level overview of
like conceptually the problem that
multi-arm Bandits are designed to solve
so now I will very briefly go over
some of the common implementations for
for these vanilla multi-on Bandits the
first of which is Epsilon greedy I'm
sure some of you are familiar with this
it's a very straightforward strategy
where you set some hyper parameter
Epsilon which is generally a small
number and with this small probability
Epsilon you select a random action right
this is exploration
and then with high probability 1 minus
Epsilon you make use of all the data
that you have and you select whatever
you think is the best action at that
point in time and that's exploitation
right and so this hyper parameter
Epsilon controls the degree to which you
explore versus exploit
so this is a very straightforward
algorithm it's a nice Baseline to have
um
but we can do a lot better than that
with more intelligent ways of navigating
this exploration exploitation dilemma
and one of these ways is the second
class of algorithms called upper
confidence bounds
so I'm not going to go into the
mathematical details of any of these but
the high level overview of what upper
confidence-bound algorithms do is they
calculate two things for you the first
thing is an expected reward associated
with each action
the second thing is a confidence
interval associated with that expected
reward right so now you have you know
how much money you think the slot
machine is going to give you and how
certain are you about that prediction
right
and now the way the algorithm selects
actions and navigates the exploration
exploitation dilemma is instead of
always selecting the action with the
highest expected reward it actually
selects the action with the highest
upper confidence bound as the name
suggests right so you could imagine you
might have slot machine one
with a very high expected reward but
you're very very uh you know confident
about that prediction and you have
another slot machine with a slightly
lower expected reward but you've sampled
from it far fewer times and so you're
far more uncertain about it so you have
a wide confidence confidence interval
the upper bound on this slot machine is
actually higher than the upper bound on
the other slot machine despite the fact
that the expected return is lower
and so this algorithm would actually
select
the latter of the two or the the one
with the lower expected reward but the
higher upper confidence bound if that
makes sense
um so it's kind of approaching this
exploration exploitation dilemma with
optimism and picking
the action with the most potential
upside at any point in time
so that's how this one works
the last algorithm for vanilla multi-arm
Bandit that I will discuss is Thompson
sampling
this is a cool approach
and what this does is it represents the
expected reward of each action with a
beta distribution
and initially it's a uniform prior so
they all start out as flat lines right
that's what this
this graph is here right everything's
flat we have no information then we
start sampling
and
the way we select actions is we simply
sample from all of these distributions
pick the action that yielded the highest
sample
play that observe a reward and then go
back and update the uh the parameters of
these distributions then over time as we
sample play actions observe rewards if
we iterate through this process we begin
to collect data about all these actions
and we can begin to form more
robust
um you know
shapes for these distributions based on
you know how we update the parameters
then you take this one step further and
as you sample and Sample and Sample you
begin to get more and more confident
about the shapes of all these
distributions that represent the
expected rewards associated with each
action
so
this kind of reflects the idea that
we're getting more and more confident in
our predictions and the way this
navigates the exploration exploitation
dilemma is through sampling right like
for example in the middle graph
you know you can see that the blue curve
is clearly
clearly seems to be the best action at
this point in time
um but that does not mean that we're
going to play that action at every given
point in time right it's entirely
possible that we could take a sample
that's on the far left tail of this blue
distribution and a sample on the far
right tail of the yellow greenish
distribution and in that case we would
play the yellow green it's just the
yellow greenish action instead of the
blue action and that's our form of
exploration in this setting
okay
so that was an overview of vanilla
multi-arm Bandit methods I will briefly
pause here that was probably a fire hose
of information and if anybody has any
questions or if anything is unclear
um
yeah speak up
any questions
I guess one question sure are there any
sort of uh
like optimality uh criteria that you use
for selecting various methods are are
these all heuristics that maybe work in
different contexts
that's a good question
um
it's hard to say I mean
in practice what we've done is just test
multiple and see which one fits our use
case best
um
I can't really say if there's a you know
a set of criteria that you should you
know look at and if you check these
boxes you use upper confidence bounds if
you check these boxes you use Thompson
sampling because they do all kind of do
the same thing it's just a different way
of doing it
um in general it appears that tons of
sampling and upper confidence bounds
they
give very similar performance in almost
all use cases in general I think
Thompson sampling might be slightly
Superior by like a hair
um
but yeah to answer your question there's
no set of like strict criteria that need
to be met for each one foreign
use cases that they were either the
after confidence funds or the County
Government
yeah definitely both of those
are known to be superior to Epsilon
greedy that is for sure
cool all right so
that was Vanilla multi-arm Bandit now
let's move into contextual multi-arm
Bandit starting with
motivating why we need to even introduce
this contextual component in the first
place
so
in order to understand why we need
contextual multi-armed Bandit we need to
First understand the shortcomings of
vanilla multi-arm Bandit as well as a b
testing
and those shortcomings are highlighted
in the following hypothetical example
suppose we are running an email campaign
in the healthcare space in this
particular example
and we need to assign one of K subject
lines to each individual right it's an
email campaign so everybody's going to
receive an email first thing they see is
the subject line so we need to pick a
subject line to assign to each of these
emails how do we do that
well before we even discuss how we do
that let's assume we have two people
first you have Sally who's a healthy
single 25 year old woman with no medical
history
the second person is essentially the
complete opposite you have John who's a
60 year old married man he has
grandchildren a number of chronic
conditions and a very long medical
history
vanilla multi-arm Bandit and a b testing
fail to recognize or just essentially
completely ignore the fact that these
people are complete opposites and what
they do is they optimize at a population
level meaning that everybody in the
population after this optimization
process is complete is going to receive
the same subject line despite the fact
that John and Sally are extremely
different and it would be very
reasonable to assume that perhaps the
subject line that's best for John is not
the same as the subject line that's best
for Sally but these existing algorithms
do not allow you to to capture that
notion right because they're context
free they don't know that John and Sally
are different
so this is why we need contextual
multi-on Bandit
contextual Bandits
as the name suggests they incorporate
this context and so they allow us to
optimize at a personalized level instead
of a population level and now that we're
optimizing at a personalized level we
can actually in theory give John the
subject line that's best for him and
sadly the subject line that's best for
her and those two subject lines
are not necessarily the same right they
can be different
so this is kind of the the core
motivation for the entire class of
contextual Bandits
thank you
so to just re-emphasize some of that
again
you know a lot of what we're doing with
our use case for this is around Behavior
change and in order for us to maximize
Behavior change of course we need to
optimize
messaging and all these sorts of things
and of course this can be extended to
other use cases as well
but that optimization needs to happen
like I said at a more personalized level
right it's great to optimize at a
population level it's better than doing
no optimization obviously but you're
still leaving
engagement and performance on the table
by failing to optimize at this
personalized level and that and that's
where a b testing falls short that's
even where mab falls short and that's
why we need the contextualization
okay so now that we've motivated the
problem I'll briefly discuss some of the
existing methods in the literature that
are commonly used for contextual Bandits
before we do that
reinforcing again
this can all of these contextual Bandit
methodologies sit within the general
reinforcement learning framework
um
with the vanilla Bandits
I said before you kind of ignore the
state now with contextual Bandits the
state is back right so this is now like
a a full picture of the high level view
of what contextual Bandits are doing
right you start in some state
based on the state you select an action
You observe a reward
based on the state in action
you update the policy to select uh the
best action you can and the objective is
to optimize that policy in order to
maximize rewards right
and so there are a couple different
methodologies that do this in the
literature that are pretty well
researched the first is from a paper
called an empirical evaluation of
Thompson sampling
um disclaimer by the way I'm not going
to go into any deep mathematical details
on either of these papers so if you're
interested in that take down the name of
these papers I highly encourage
everybody to read them they're
interesting they do a very good job of
explaining all these things clearly
um the math is there if you want to talk
about the math after this talk I'd be
happy to have a private discussion about
that but that's beyond the scope of this
um
but anyway yeah two methods here
Thompson sampling approach versus UCB
approach
um what's common between these two is
the use of a model and the use of the
model allows us to incorporate the
contextual features which we'll call
some Vector X right so both of these are
have some Black Box model they take in
the contextual features X and they use
those features to Output an expected
reward associated with each action and
then based on that expected reward
we of course decide which action to play
so on the method on the left the
Thompson sampling approach
the model that's used here is
essentially a Bayesian logistic
regression model where the weights in
the model have prior distributions and
at each point in time we sample from
these distributions for each weight we
get an expected reward based on those
samples
we update the parameters of those
distributions based on the reward and we
iterate through that process over and
over and over again so it's kind of like
Thompson sampling but the sampling now
happens on the weights of the model
rather than
simply the actions themselves
the approach on the right a contextual
abandoned approach to personalized news
article recommendation the actual
algorithm here is called Lynn UCB stands
for linear upper confidence bounds
and this is a very straightforward
method the name does quite a good job of
summarizing what exactly it does it's
basically just a linear model that maps
from these contextual features X
to an expected reward and in addition to
that it does some linear algebra to
compute a confidence interval around
this expected reward
and some exactly the same way that the
upper confidence bound vanilla
algorithms navigate the exploration
exploitation dilemma this does the same
thing right now we just have a model
that allows us to get more personalized
and more expressive estimates for
expected reward but we're still doing
the same thing right we're picking the
action with the highest upper confidence
bound
so those were some of the more uh
commonly known existing solutions for
contextual Bandits there's a couple
other interesting ones dealing with you
know deep neural networks that are
beyond the scope of this again if you're
interested in those we could talk after
but that was some of what's in the word
in the literature well what we've
implemented is slightly different and I
will explain at a very high level
again without going into mathematical
details I'll explain what we have
implemented ourselves
so
like those existing methods that I just
described we also leverage models this
is how we take in context and how we are
able to optimize a personalized rather
than a population level
so we build a model
that takes in whatever features from our
context and outputs some expected reward
associated with each action
then based on this model output we place
individuals into cohorts where each
cohort is made up of individuals for
whom a certain action is best so cohort
one is all of the people for whom our
model says action a is best cohort 2 is
all of the people for whom our model
says action B is best and so on
and then what we do with these cohorts
is we throw a vanilla
you don't literally throw a vanilla
multiple but you you put a vanilla
multi-arm Bandit over each of these
cohorts and what that allows to happen
is now
you've divided the population into these
sub-segments and each segment gets its
own Bandit that can converge to a
different optimal action and so instead
of now finding just one action that's
best for the whole population you can
find an action that's best for cohort
one an action that's best for cohort too
and this allows you to optimize at a
slightly more granular level than
vanilla multi-arm Bandit
foreign
so that was a really high level view of
the algorithm that we implemented and
now I'll go over some of the results
that were quite encouraging in our small
proof of concept
so
this slide here the graph on the left
this basically just demonstrates that
our algorithm is doing what we intended
it to do so the horizontal dashed line
is vanilla multi-on Bandit it's a flat
constant line because vanilla multi-arm
Bandit is at the population level right
now each of the Clusters
each bar corresponds to a different
action and each cluster you can see has
a different optimal action which is
desirable of course and furthermore you
can see that in each cluster the optimal
action does
nearly just as good if not far better
than vanilla multi-arm Bandit so in
clusters two three and four specifically
you can see that the algorithm is able
to identify for these cohorts a specific
action that far outperforms whatever
action vanilla multi-arm Bandit would
have suggested and this is reassuring to
us this is showing us that our algorithm
is in fact doing what we intended it to
do
one thing to point out here in cluster
two you can see that bar is outrageously
High and the reason for that is because
cluster 2 happens to be a very unique
group of people that is the sample size
is quite small and that's why we're able
to get such a
outrageously High success rate there
that's not standard for this use case
but
um
yeah the point to be driven home here is
that each cluster gets its own action
these actions outperform whatever action
vanilla multi-arm Bandit shows and the
reason it's able to do this is again
because of because we're splitting them
into relevant cohorts that evidently
have some meaningful information encoded
in them
so now to more clearly show that
contextual Bandits do in fact outperform
vanilla multi-arm Bandits as well as a b
testing
we've constructed a simple graph here
that shows number of successes over time
and so as you can see as we progress
Through Time contextual Bandits do
separate themselves from the competition
you see that light pink dot
ends up being higher than all the rest
which is again reassuring us that our
contextual Bandits are in fact providing
some additional value over vanilla
abandons talk a bit a little bit slower
more detail about this graph
okay oh yeah what each dot is okay so I
guess that's not entirely clear yeah so
the
yeah the vanilla mab dot that's
hopefully that's self-explanatory that's
vanilla maybe
um the a b testing and the best a B test
that needs a little bit of explanation
um
so a b testing this dot corresponds to
when you're actually running the A B
test right so this is if in your slot
machine example you've assigned you know
20 to each slot machine and you're
running that that's during that time and
then once you finish the A B test you do
some analysis and maybe you determine
slot machine three is best
that's what this dot is is measuring
against so that would be the success
rate if you sent slot machine 3 to
everybody
so
we're comparing contextual bandages
against vanilla maybe the actual process
of a b testing as well as we're
comparing it also against
the actual best result from a d testing
and so that's
kind of a meaningful distinction because
this shows that contextual Bandits not
only outperform maybe testing while it's
doing that testing but also it
outperforms it even after a b testing
has converged to whatever it thinks the
best action is
um
yeah so that should summarize that I
think one
is the initial state right yes okay and
by
hand five we can see
it's a clear yeah time five is pretty
clear and then T equals six again these
these times are kind of arbitrary
um abstractions from the real time but
Yeah by time five or six
um it's pretty clear that contextual
Bandits separate themselves from from
the competition it's interesting to note
that actually the closest competitor to
the contextual Bandits is the best baby
the best result in the AV test
um
but again that's not a fair comparison
because in order to even arrive at the
point where you have this you have to
first go through that which is the worst
performing so
who's the thought yeah and also of
course this results is based on
simulation and based on the setting we
use in the simulation yeah so this may
not be generalizable to other settings
yes that is a good point this is this
was done through simulation so this is
not real data um
of course we trust our simulations but
to take it with a grain of salt
any questions about any of this
implementation stuff
yeah go ahead
um wait for the vanilla multi-arm band
like theories shouldn't that be as time
progresses yet obviously like the class
IV test right this would be like correct
yeah I don't know maybe it's a specific
type of decision yeah in theory you're
right yes right okay yeah
yeah I imagine as we
you know if we extrapolate it a little
further it might get there we cut it off
kind of early for the sake of fitting it
all on the side but but yes in theory
you're right
yeah so how do you decide on how how
deep you want to go with this I'm
thinking about a parallel between
determining a value for k k means
clustering in one scenario you could say
well every five people have their own
Bandit right but where do you stop and
is there a heuristic that you might
um you know put out there for folks to
consider so you're talking about
determining the number of cohorts that
were dividing people into
because ultimately that translates into
bifurcations within your experimental
framework yes and there's a complexity
trade-off that you have to manage there
as well
yeah the general heuristic that that
we've been using is to select the number
of cohorts to be the same as the number
of actions that you're you're choosing
from so like in the example of the email
campaign that we were doing before if
you have like five subject lines that
are candidate subject lines then you'd
have you'd run this model with five
cohorts under the assumption that each
of those cohorts would capture people
for whom subject line one is best and
then subject line two is best in that
kind of thing because that's kind of
intuitively what you would imagine or
what you would hope that the model does
that make sense
foreign
how are you getting the data to train a
model that does the prediction of which
intervention would work best for
the the
individuals so that you can cohort are
you running like some kind of a B test
before to gather empirical data and then
using that data to build the model yeah
yeah we have
quite a bit of data that we've collected
over the years through a b tests so we
have a whole bunch of randomized data
that we're using to to build these
models here yeah besides that at least
each timestamp of the whole process
in general the ideal scenario will be to
also collect some random data collect
some
exploration data and of course how much
exploration data we collect at a further
time point is TBD and that also presents
itself for trade-off between exploration
and exploitation
right you can imagine like in whatever
population we're running this on maybe
you cut out 10 of that population and
just assign them random stuff at any
point in time just for a comparison
group and for also collecting more data
cool
all right
so now I'll briefly touch on some
broader applications of this
um
it can be used like we've been saying in
basically any setting where
personalized optimization would be
beneficial right so you can imagine this
would work very well in online
advertising or maybe you have some set
of advertisements that you need to
pick which one to show to each user that
would be a very straightforward case
where contextual Bandits would be useful
another case like I said before email
optimization right if you have to figure
out which subject lines to send to
somebody which specific email template
to send to somebody
these are all cases where contextual
Bandits would be useful
and lastly you could even you know widen
that scope to just content
recommendation as a whole you know
anytime you have some piece of content
you have users and you have to decide
how to you know allocate content to
users or assign content to users
contextual Bandits can help you do that
in a personalized way
it is important to note here that you
know specifically with content
recommendation if your action space gets
really really large like to the point
where you have hundreds of thousands or
millions of actions then these
contextual Bandit approaches May begin
to fail you they do better in smaller
action spaces once you get to these
super large action spaces you might be
better served by a more classical
recommendation system
but any any situation where your action
space is relatively small
or reasonably sized contextual Bandits
should be very helpful and again all of
these fall under the bucket of
personalization
foreign
so the very last thing we wanted to
touch on is to kind of preview this
python package that we're developing
that will capture a lot of this
functionality that we've been working on
it'll be called optumwift it's a python
package that will include among other
things functionality for contextual
Bandits so you can think of it as you
know being kind of a One-Stop shop for
any sort of contextual Bandit
functionality that you'll have
you can build your own cmeb agents apply
it to whatever use case you have
um we'll build in tools for you to run
your own simulations to get a sort of
proof of concept down because that is
kind of a
a barrier here to entry is that it's
hard to
show the value of this without actually
doing it because you have to collect all
this data in real time and you can't
really test that without actually doing
it and so that's where simulations are
useful because then you can you can do
it without actually spending the money
or using the resources to run it in
production
so we'll build all this out in a python
package we're working on it it's not out
yet
um but keep your eyes peeled for that in
the future
um
and yeah
that is all that's contextual multi-arm
Bandits so any questions are welcome
[Applause]
say your cohort is dropping people and
bringing in people is it dynamic in that
sense what will change the nature of the
cohort in order to fix it a bunch of
people that's a really good question
that's something that we're still kind
of playing around with
um there's a couple different ways you
can sort of handle the you know the
dynamic movement of people from cohort
to cohort
um
yeah I'm just going to leave it at that
it's it's like a it's a challenging
problem that I'm thinking through right
now
um
but
there's a couple ways to do it for the
sake of this talk we'll leave it at that
if you want to talk more about it after
we can go into details um but yeah good
question though it's a very relevant
problem
yeah
there is if
you're separating people into cohort
straight they get their comparison
between other questions
um
I did actually play around with some
more standard clustering approaches like
a simple K means clustering instead of
you know using this whole model and
clustering based on the output of the
model and these unsupervised clustering
approaches generally did not yield as
good performance as the model clustering
did
um
I don't have a real explanation as to
why other than that the model is
you know it's directly modeling the
things that we're interested in and so
naturally if you cluster People based on
that I think it makes logical sense that
those clusters would perform better than
something that is unsupervised
um but yeah the performance was better
we did test that and also we use the
classroom here just as a example so
think about the other two
um
popular methods of doing contextual and
maybe cmab we can apply
um all of those into our
contextualization steps
thank you
a little bit relevant to the first
question but like custom on modal
increasingly and though the uh date
address or like a concept drift
it would be handled in like retraining
right it wouldn't just be like this
model that you fit once and just leave
it there right it's gonna we're gonna
iterate on it so theoretically if the
distribution of the data does start to
move around that should be captured in
when the model is retrained that's why
um having a contextualized Excel
exploration layer is important yeah so
that we know when that's the current
contextualization fail to perform and
then we need to retrain and rebuild
yes
kind of a wild question but like to the
content personalization that you were
talking about and kind of like pulling
down that action in space
do you know anything about like any kind
of like methods that are being confused
you know because it's really tricky like
you know image classifications yeah yeah
there are
I read a couple papers that uh describe
different ways of condensing that action
space down into something that's
reasonable so that you can apply a
contextual Bandit
uh they're fairly complicated
um and I don't know if I don't remember
if they actually showed Superior
performance to like a more classical
recommendation system that's kind of
designed for large action spaces
But to answer your question yes there
are approaches that do that they're
interesting I can point you to some
papers if you're interested
um
it's it's cool it's challenging to do
it's not a straightforward problem
to do that yeah good question
yeah is the success of the intervention
buying conversion generally
interchange yeah yeah like in in the
example of the emails yes it's measured
in terms of open rate so we wanted to
measure that behavior change long term
a good application it's more like
compared like comparable maybe
well it's it's relevant for long-term
Behavior change in the sense that like
opening the email is the first step in
that behavior change funnel right like
if they don't open the email they're not
going to see the content or do anything
right
um of course it's not completely
reflective of behavior change because
even once they open the email they have
to consume the rest of the content do
whatever the action is and so on right
so there's more steps in that funnel um
so it's kind of just like a small piece
of that puzzle but um I wouldn't say
it's totally irrelevant but you are
right it's not it's not quite like this
it's not the be-all end-all metric for
Behavior change but the methodology is
definitely applicable to a long-term
like a medical cost saving type of
metrics yeah they just needed to
optimize our rewards towards that
yeah and of course
um I would say more time than the
contextual matter and Bandit is that
special applicable to digital
experiments that have a shorter feedback
loop then like you have to wait for a
few months a half half a year a year to
observe you know the next set of State
foreign
thanks everybody
[Applause]